- what's up everyone welcome to
simulation we are gonna be talking about
our thoughts on mental health all right
so what's going on right now with mental
health okay
probably one of the biggest things
that's going on with mental health right
now is this social media we have people
that are thinking that the amount of
followers that they have is equivalent
the amount of likes that they get that
these things are equivalent to their net
worth that they're it's equivalent to
their self-worth and that's making it so
that these figures that have so many
followers and fame are now making it
young people also feel like they need to
have followers and fame otherwise
they're not successful they don't feel
good now don't get me wrong there's
something also very important in the
process of young people seeing people as
idols and then working their ass off to
become really good in the world a good
source of value and utility I think that
is the first thing with mental health we
have a lot of kids that go to school
every day that get bullied they don't
fit in we've had people on our show
talking about people not fitting in the
not fitting in is a big deal and we
think parents teachers counselors
community members if we could just help
13 year olds 15 year olds and let them
know hey like high school is only one
small portion of your life and even
though right now it might feel like you
don't fit in there's gonna be people
that you fit in with and that it's a
it's that this is a small small portion
of your life but immediately when you're
done with this that you're gonna move on
and go on to do other things with people
that you'll find that you'll like so I
think a lot of times young kids think
that this is the end-all be-all
most important thing that's going on
with their health and their mindset when
they're young and when they're getting
bullied or these other things are
happening to them and I think that's one
of the reasons why we see a lot of
people do things like take weaponry and
go and make killings now this is not a
statement about gun control because the
a second Amendment rights for your
weapons is something that is people hold
very close to them it's so that a
tyrannical government could not bring
itself up and and use military force to
go and take control financial control of
the people and mind control of the
people in that sense land control so you
can have your weaponry for self-defense
in that sense against the tyrannical
government or against tyrannical
neighbors maybe so nobody's saying to
control them in that sense but it's more
so that all of the way that somehow
people get this mentality of okay I am
unstable now I want to go and make harm
on other people how do we limit their
ability to make harm on other people
okay / prevent the mental health issues
from happening in the first place but
also sometimes the mental health issue
goes unseen and then the next step is
how do we make a barrier so that's
difficult even more difficult for them
to get weaponry so another aspect about
this mental health goes to the way that
we make it basically has become a game
of high scores people see that they're
you know being bullied they have no
friends they don't know that or same
thing in the nine-to-five space that
they hate their work they hate their
life situation and so what better way
than to go and hurt other people so when
the media turns around and shows their
picture shows their name says they've
hurt seven people or 12 people or 14
people that it treats it like a score
we need to stop [ __ ] treating it like
a scoreboard when it's a scoreboard
we're making it even more attractive for
people to want to do that process
stop saying their name stop showing
their pictures and even stop making it
such a a massive deal make it less of a
massive deal of course it's important to
make it news but also to not highlight
the killer highlight the person that
saved the situation highlight the people
that saved the situation and highlight
the fae the the the the families and
like what the kids were doing or what
the adults were doing that got hurt make
them like heroes in that sense as well
so there's a whole different media
approach to it as well there's a whole
different approach to it on the social
side of things on the social media the
whole putting this pressure onto young
people to become successful so quickly
and we live in the Western world we
don't even realize that we have so much
pressure on us to succeed you go into
other places in the world
and even in other modern places in the
world people are more chill there at
least sitting down at cafes and talking
and there if they find somebody on the
street they'll sit and talk to them for
an hour about life or about whatever
they get deeper into maybe emotions and
into their family and all these things
but it's fine in the West we're like
quick quick quick phone call text
message email calls running around got
to go to the next thing but that is also
causing so much pressure on us to go and
make money build the future and we don't
have as much time to go and relax and
and work on our mental health really so
it's important for us to figure this out
and one last thing that I'll leave you
with about mental health is that if you
take a look at Anthony Bourdain this was
something that
read that really resonated with me was
that it's not about what you experience
but how you experience it not what you
experience about how you experience it
so if you're experiencing your moment to
moment life with a sense of gratitude
for every moment of being alive and for
gratitude that you have electricity and
water and food and shelter in these
basic necessities you are going to be
living a life of abundance but the
moment that you say that this isn't
enough
I need more I'm sad that I don't have
more that you see that somebody else is
bullying you and that you treating it
like something that's horribly happening
that you need to take your life because
of that but you need to take your life
because you're not successful enough
because you're depressed a lot of rich
people are actually some of the most
depressed people because they've made
the Happiness plateaus around 70k once
you make in the Western world 70k you
don't actually become any happier after
70,000 because all these basic needs in
the Western world are met and fulfilled
so once you get to this whole rich
status then you can't even tell who's
trying to be your friend whose authentic
versus someone that's trying to be your
friend to ask you for money and stuff so
good luck with this world that we've
built working on our mental health
that's why we have these conversations
that's why we did a thoughts on episode
on mental health is that let's figure
out how to build a better social fabric
moving forward to make sure that we can
work on mental health we live in a place
of San Francisco where we have amazing
technological advancement but we also
have a homeless epidemic here we have a
lot of people that are on the streets
that are using drugs that don't have
homes that have hard tough mental health
situations and so why haven't we figured
out how to how to help how to help make
mends how to help eradicate suffering
let's figure out how to make this work
that's why we have these thoughts on
thanks for tuning in everyone if you had
a good time go and share it with two
people have them talk to two people go
and make
something with content don't just
consume but go create thanks everyone
much love